[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt in
meinem ersten majors video habe ich euch
gezeigt wie man die spiegelglatte
zubereitet in diesem video heute folgen
ein paar basics weilerswist horten ist
immer ganz wichtig dass die unterlage
also der untergrund stimmt daher muss
immer eine torte vorbereitet werden und
eingefroren werden damit dann darüber
die glasur gegossen werden kann und die
dann eben auch schon fest wird in diesem
video stelle ich euch mal vier
komponenten vor die ich wirklich super
wichtig finde meine torte sollen nämlich
gut schmecken einen frucht kann haben
einen leckeren boden aus schokolade oder
weiße schokolade und dann noch einen
kran schicken boden und am ende des
videos zeige ich euch wie ihr auch ganz
einfach ein mail place machen könnt
nämlich mit hilfe von diesem packungen
die gibt's einmal in weiß dunkel und
rosa und so könnt ihr auch in
minutenschnelle einmal wirklich zu
bereiten
los geht es aber erstmal meter
vorbereitung zuerst bereite ich jetzt
den teig vor
dafür nehme ich einen braun zeigt das
ist wirklich einer meiner lieblings teil
weil ja schön saftig ist und ich mache
hier einmal der dunkle variation und
eine helle variationen die zutaten seht
ihr hier
dafür brauchen sie etwas butter zucker
etwas kaffee schwarzer herren schokolade
oder twitter schokolade salzmangel
extrakt eier gemahlene haselnüsse oder
mandeln kakaopulver mehl und backpulver
zuerst wird die butter mit dem zucker
und dem café in einem topf geschmolzen
und bei der flüssigkeit könnt ihr
entscheiden ob ihr espresso mit milch
rum likör oder andere rungen da kommt
die schokolade mit dazu und wird solange
verrührt bis sie geschmolzen ist die
schokoladenmasse lasse ich jetzt
abkühlen und verriet dann mit dem salz
vanille extrakt und den eiern und zum
schluss kommen noch die trockenen
zutaten also die gemahlenen nüssen
kakaopulver mehl und backpulver dazu
[Musik]
den teig fühle ich dann in ein
vorbereitetes backblech und dann kann
dieser schon gebacken werden
[Musik]
für die helle variante tausche ich
einfach die schokolade aus neben weiße
schokolade und ein bisschen familie
[Musik]
der zweite bestandteil sind bei mir die
frucht einlagen damit könnt ihr ganz
tolle effekte erzählen und vor allem
einen richtig guten geschmack mit
reinbringen
da könnt ihr euch das grundrezept auf
meinem blog anschauen und wir können
wirklich ganz viele verschiedene früchte
verwenden
und ich bin der die frucht einlagen
immer mit etwas ak 20 in gelee mitte das
hat natürlich den vorteil dass sie ein
gefrieren kann
und daneben auch auf vorrat herstellen
kann
[Musik]
jetzt ist die vorlage gekocht und jetzt
müsst ihr sie natürlich irgendwo rein
stellen entweder nimmt jetzt einen tort
bringt er etwas kleiner ist als eure
silikon backform es kommt da jetzt
wirklich drauf an was wenn er vor mir
verwendet ich habe jetzt zum beispiel
auch hier diese muffin silikonform wo
ich später die workplace cakes rein
machen werde
das heißt da brauche ich eine kleine
frucht einlage beim herz und bei den
runden ist es so beim runden zum
beispiel brauche ich auch eine kleine
runde fläche man kann aber auch so
kleine kegel zum beispiel machen nach
schöne spitzen also da könnte wirklich
alles verwenden
ich habe ich jetzt die längliche form
dies sogar passend zur silikon backform
und die habe ich jetzt ausgelegt und so
könnt ihr euch eure frucht einlagen
einfach füllen und dann einfrieren
hier verteile ich eben schön damit ich
später eine richtig schöne glatte vorne
raus bekommen
[Musik]
ihr könnt im prinzip aber auch die
frucht einwaage direkt in dem silikon
formen machen
ich will einfach nur ganz wenig ein dann
habe ich eine kleine schicht lasst die
einfrieren und kann sie dann später auch
zum filmen verwenden
[Musik]
der dritte bestandteil meiner watchlist
orte ist die creme
hier könnt ihr jetzt im prinzip jede
creme nehmen die ihr gerne habt auch auf
meinem blog stehen ganz viele rezepte
ich mache jetzt eine standards creme auf
same etwas frischkäse in doppelreihe
stufe sommerbad vorne links praktisch
flüssiger weißer schokolade
die sahne habe ich jetzt mit dem
sommerbad halb steif geschlagen und
jetzt kann ich den frischkäse mit der
kürzung schokolade und vanille extrakt
verwirrung
[Musik]
jetzt verbindet beide cremes und schlagt
es dann steil
[Musik]
und wenn dich dann spritzbeutel da kann
ich ein bisschen besser und sauberer
arbeiten da kann ich jetzt hier vorne
die spitze wegschneiden und dann schon
mal einen teil der probleme in die form
hinein stritt und da kommen jetzt die
gefrorenen frucht elemente rein
die cremes jetzt glatt verstrichen ich
hatte die jetzt noch kurz im kühlschrank
denn die teile hier war noch nicht
gefroren
jetzt sind sie gefroren und ich kann sie
jetzt hier raus nehmen und das ist eben
auch wichtig und kann jetzt hier
praktisch reinstecken
ihr könnt jetzt theoretisch auch zum
beispiel eine große platte gießen aus
dieser frucht einlage zu schneiden und
eine platte reinlegen sowie ihr gerne
möchte
da kommen jetzt noch mal creme drüber
und dann der ausgeschnittene gebackene
boden
[Musik]
und damit sie den teig einfacher form
entsprechend zu schneiden und reinlegen
und theoretisch könnte das jetzt so
lassen oder ihr macht noch eine vierte
komponente so wie ich es mache es hier
noch ein bisschen spanisch mit rein und
mache jetzt hier noch einen boden aus
cornflakes mandeln und schokolade
aber solange kommt das schon mal ins
gefrierfach für den crispy boden
verwendet jetzt kuvertüre weiß vollmilch
oder auch dunkle kuvertüre und die wird
dann geschmolzen und zwar zwei drittel
ein drittel die impf methode das heißt
die kuvertüre wird zuerst zerkleinert
und am schnellsten geht es wenn man sie
rast wird dann kommen zwei drittel der
kuvertüre über ein warmes wasserbad und
sobald es geschmolzen ist kommt das
restliche drittel dazu und dann hat sie
die perfekte temperatur und konsistenz
hier gebe ich jetzt konflikt mit rein
und mandeln bei der dunklen version gebe
ich zum beispiel auch reis christie's
mit rein also da könnt ihr auch spielen
und variieren wie ihre stadt
[Musik]
jetzt kommt diese masse hier noch oben
drauf und wenn ich es später raus stürze
ist der krems boden ganz unten und
wichtig bei den silicon frommen und bei
den euroclassics ist einfach nur dass
man sauber arbeitet und hat mal richtig
schöne feine schichten und danach muss
die torte erst einmal komplett durch
gefrieren das heißt am besten über nacht
[Musik]
ab ins gefrierfach
meine torten sind jetzt gefragt jetzt
kann ich sie mit dem miracles überziehen
entweder macht ihr jetzt eure eigene
mail adresse gast
da gibt es ja bereits ein rezept von mir
ist aber ein bisschen aufwendig oder ihr
nehmt einfach die fertige mischung und
zwar gibt es die von küchler einmal in
weiß dunkel braun und rosa und die
zubereitung ist echt super einfach ich
habe jetzt hier 400 milliliter milch in
einem topf und lasst sie kurz aufkochen
jetzt kocht die milch jetzt habe ich
gleich dein herz wieder ausgemacht und
jetzt könnt ihr einfach eure
lieblingsfarbe nehmen ich trage jetzt
mal mit rosa an
und dann kann das nur place prüfer ohne
klümpchen eingeführt werden
[Musik]
und jetzt merkt man schon dass es mit
laser etwas dicker wird jetzt müsste es
aber unbedingt handwarm abkühlen lassen
das heißt auf etwa 35 grad und dann
werden wir gleich die top damit
reduzieren
[Musik]
jetzt hat das meer ist die perfekte
temperatur
falls es mal zu kalt geworden ist könnte
es auch immer wieder erwärmen aber nicht
aufkommen lassen
ich arbeite immer gern mit einem
digitalen thermometer da kann man die
temperatur wirklich super messen
ansonsten einfach den kleinen finger
rein stecken uns muss schön lauwarm sein
darf nicht so dick und auch nicht zu
dünn sein damit jetzt die luftbläschen
verschwinden werde ich hier durch ein
sieb durch geben und zwar einen teil
den rest habe ich noch ein und füllt
dann mit dazu
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier meine torte aus der
silikonform herausgenommen affen
abkühlen gitter und unten drunter ein
blech jetzt könnt ihr gerne die 23
farben ein bisschen verrühren und dann
komplett
[Musik]
und so lasse ich das war ok jetzt
abtropfen für etwa zehn minuten und dann
kann ich es von der treppe runter nehmen
und so werde ich jetzt noch die zwei
anderen farben verwenden also einmal tag
und einmal weist und werden jetzt auch
über
[Musik]
und jetzt mit dekoriert ich nehme jetzt
hier für den rand unten einfach noch ein
paar mandeln
so könnt ihr zum beispiel auch verdecken
mit komplett alles runter gelaufen ist
dann könnt ihr hier zum beispiel noch
ein paar früchte dazu setzen und mit ein
bisschen glitzer dekoriert
[Musik]
nachdem über zehn tatorten muss
natürlich die majors erstmal fest werden
danach können wir sie aus dekorieren und
dann lacht er die torte am besten bei
zimmertemperatur auftauen
ich habe jetzt meine je nach größe
können dass eine halbe stunde oder
stunde stehen lassen weil es ihr die
torte erst später verzehren wollt dann
in den kühlschrank auf jeden fall
stellen so dass einfach das innere
wieder schön weich wird hier seht ihr
den anschnitt ich finde es richtig schön
die marke ist wird auch schön fest das
heißt man kann dann auch wirklich tragen
lang ohne das was verschmiert und beim
anschnitt für schmidt deswegen auch
nichts und dann sieht alles richtig
schön glatt aus ich hoffe ich konnte
euch in diesem video einfach ein paar
anregungen geben für eure füllungen und
natürlich auch für die dekoration für
weitere ideen schaut ihr einfach auf
meinem blog vorbei auf kellys - blog.de
ich freue mich schon auf eure torten auf
eure fotos schreibt mir auf jeden fall
und ich freue mich darauf also viel spaß
beim nachbacken und dekorieren und bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]